Grouper Republican senators are pushing
a doc a deal to provide amnesty to about
two million illegal immigrants the
proposal which is being promoted by
seven Republicans including Lindsey
Graham of South Carolina would offer a
path to citizenship for all the
so-called dreamers even those who
weren't part of daca they would be
eligible for welfare after five years
here the diversity lottery would be
quote abolished but those visas would
simply be reallocated to other programs
with the same purpose a little sleight
of hand there for you it even allows the
parents of daca recipients who legally
entered that America as adults and cause
this whole problem in the first place to
get renewable work permits to stay in
this country if you care about borders
it is a terrible deal really a parody of
a bill apparently designed to win over
Democrats were threatening to government
shutdown over daca congresswoman martha
mcsalley represents the arizona she's
running to replace jeff flake in the
senate and she joins us tonight
congressman thanks thanks for night
thanks a man you're not only a member of
congress you spent many years in uniform
many years over 20 i think is how do you
feel about the democrats saying
basically out loud provide amnesty we're
gonna stop paying our troops it's
infuriating tucker this is the point i
brought up in the white house meeting
last week and i was i was moved when i
heard dick durbin say there's lives
hanging in the balance or something like
that and I was like move to jump in and
say the only lives that are hanging the
balance right now are those are military
the men and women that are serving
overseas putting their lives in harm's
way there is a fake deadline created by
the Democrats holding them hostage and
while our troops are over there risking
their lives for us these guys are
picking around excuse my language trying
to come up with some issue that's not
even in a top 20 priority of the
American people so we need to look to
more legislation like the bill I
introduced last week that addresses the
priorities of the American people the
border security yes ending chain
migration ending the visa lottery
addressing sanctuary cities asylum
reform unaccompanied minor reform Eve
Arif I this is a reasonable bill to
address the root causes of daca that we
can continue to work on over the next
few weeks and months there's no crisis
here and they are holding our troops
hostage for this issue that has nothing
to do with funding our military it's
infuriating assumptions so the bill that
you're back
King is literally mainstream in that
it's major components are right in the
middle of the polling on the question
okay so but the Senate the Senate
version which is being supported really
driven by Lindsey Graham and Jeff Flake
Lindsey Graham said to someone I know
recently Jeff Flake will do whatever I
tell him to do and a bunch of other
Republican senators very far from what
you're proposing it is can you win them
to your side we have to look this is a
priority of the American people and we
worked for four and a half months on
this bill if you look at the White House
put out a document with 70 requests in
it we've worked through them all this is
not all of them this is a very
reasonable prioritized proposal that
focuses on security first and foremost
of the American people addresses the
loopholes in our system some of them are
creating threats like we've seen with
the terrorist attacks in New York City
they have to be closed with the chain
migration into visa lottery that Visa
Visa Lottery system it also ensures that
if we're willing to do something on daca
if we get to that place that we are not
finding ourselves in this situation
again in another one five or ten years
this is a very reasonable approach it
should be the starting point and that's
where we need to sit down and negotiate
in good faith Congressman martha
mcsalley of arizona thanks a lot for
coming on thanks I appreciate it